- [Host] The next speaker,
is a New Yorker,
he's an amazing leader.
And he's Russian, too!
So, he's Gary!
(crowd applauding)
(hip hop music)
- [Female] Gary Vaynerchuk?
(crowd cheers)
- You're not shooting high enough.
So here in Toronto,
big day.
Got some media in the morning here
that I'm about to do and
then we've got the Haste
and Hustle Conference
which is a bunch of events
speech, Q&A, lunch.
And then later, the pop-up
for the K-Swiss launch,
which we're both rocking.
Tyler is not rocking it.
But he's rocking other K-Swiss.
I'm impressed by that.
- [Female] I'm not.
(laughs)
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] I gotta run to the
I'm going to the pop-up.
- [Female] Meet us at the plaza!
- [Gary] You guys, I have
some free passes to the
conference I'm speaking it.
Anybody,
yeah?
Anybody else need a pass
for the conference today?
Good, good good good
good good good good good.
Get me outta here.
Thank you.
- [Interviewer] So, what are the three
most important things to keep in mind
for someone who wants to build a
public face and personal
brand in your mind?
- Number one, you better be a good person.
You better recognize that
if you have skeletons,
you better own them, or know that
they're going to be vulnerable.
Because that game has
that ship has sailed.
Something I started talking about in 2008.
In Crush It, it obviously is now
very real 'cause of all
the stuff that's happened
with the Me Too movement
which is phenomenal.
That's number one.
Number two,
you have to have empathy
for your audience.
If you're the kind of person
that gets upset that johnnypants99
says you're ugly or you're stupid,
you might as well close up shop now.
I have empathy for people that think I'm a
snake oil salesman or
full of crap or not good
or who knows?
Or I curse too much.
You have to have empathy,
because that's what
allows you to move forward
instead of being combative
with the audience
which is your ultimate asset.
Number three, you have to respect context.
The same picture does not work across
Facebook, Instagram, Pinterest, Snapchat.
And you have to have understanding of the
context of the psychology of the person
when they're on that platform
to make the content pop and resonate.
So, the religion of context,
not just content, is essential.
The single biggest
reason I maintain Gary V
is to be a doer.
- Right.
- I mean to me my personal brand is about
top of the funnel awareness,
but way more importantly,
I'm a practitioner.
I post on Instagram.
I reply to DM's.
- You get it, you got it.
- I have to,
listen, you have to
know what you're doing.
What's some advice you
would give to somebody
that just doesn't know what
they want to do, right now?
- Just speak your truth, right?
Speak your truth.
Including that you have depression
or that you don't know what you're doing
or that you're really good at cutting hair
or that you love The Smurfs.
I think the truth is
the biggest win, right?
And I think that for me,
that has really played
out in our society today.
There's no more hiding.
The internet is all encompassing.
And nobody's gonna be able to front.
Like, if you're not
motivated and optimistic,
motivational content's
not going to work for you.
You know, if you aren't
thoughtful and smart
about sports, you're not gonna win.
You can only win on two things,
the thing that you understand the best,
or the thing that you're most passionate
or authentic about.
Those are the only two winning formulas.
I think too many people want to
fake it 'til they make it,
or project someone they're not.
Which is why 99 percent
of people are losing.
- Social media has been
really big for a while,
you're obviously a massive influencer.
What do you think is next
when it comes to brands
cutting through in a
very fragmented market
when it comes to digital?
- Voice.
Voice.
- Alright.
- I'm obsessed.
I have not seen anything
that reminds me of
the iPhone with social
networks on top of it.
The way I feel about
Google, Apple Pod and Alexa,
we have not felt the apps on
top of the voice thing yet.
In a lot of scenarios,
voice is a far more effective,
efficient medium to deliver information.
When I'm brushing my teeth,
it's better for me to listen to my day.
When I'm driving, it's better for me
to listen or commute.
So to me, I care about communication.
I'm not as
I'm not bright enough or as smart as
my partner in crime here
to understand kind of the frameworks,
the technologies, the
inventions that are needed to.
What I'm very good at is understanding
consumer behavior, and what we're gonna
do with those things,
and so for me, voice is emerging
because of AI and technology advances
by some of the biggest internet companies
in the world.
And that's why I'm very
passionate about it.
The internet's the highway.
The big companies are the tollbooths.
You've gotta pay those tollbooths
but you have to be very
strategic in how you pay.
Facebook and Instagram and
Google are great for me
because I look at them as frienemies.
They're places where I can get awareness,
but I don't want to be
at the mercy of them.
Which is why I'm prolific
across all platforms.
Because I'm diversifying.
Media companies should be in trouble,
if they put all their eggs
in the Facebook bucket.
That is ludicrous strategy.
Where's your podcast?
Where's your original show?
Where's your vlog?
Where's your email list?
Where's your CRM?
Where's your text messaging platform?
I wish people understood how hard it is
to have a business that
does a million dollars.
- It's not sexy.
It's so far from being sexy.
- I would also add the part
that I'm most concerned about
which is that it's awfully lonely.
And I think most people
you have to be unbelievably
strong emotionally
to be able to deal with loneliness.
And in a world where I think
we're talking more about
depression and mental health,
I want to make that a bigger
part of the conversation.
Because I think it leads to a bad place.
It is a very lonely sport.
Because not only are you lonely
you're responsible for everything,
everybody's watching.
And judging.
- Judging, yeah.
- Your parents, your best friends,
everybody.
That's lonely.
- [Male] Hellooo.
- [Gary] Hello.
- How are you, Lance.
Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] It's a pleasure.
How are you?
- Thank you so much for this.
- Hi, Chris, we're the video team.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- [Male] Do you have
any music requests?
- Do you have any Gunna?
- [Male] What are we on Spotify right now?
- Actually I'm gonna flip it up.
What about some Nipsey Hussle?
- [Male] What is it?
- [Gary] Nipsey.
N-i-p-s, yep there he is.
Yep.
Right there.
- [Photographer] Arms crossed.
(hip hop music)
(laughs)
- [Male] On the portraits
and the expressions.
- Alright, perfect.
- [Gary] Being influential means
that when you do something,
meaning you say something,
you wear something,
you write something,
you act on something,
other people are affected by that.
And want to be inspired to
then also do that as well,
or some variation thereof, so
I think it's somebody who has an impact on
other people at scale.
And influences, creates an
action from their own actions.
As far as what's
the difference between an entrepreneur
and a wantrepreneur
I mean, look.
Entrepreneurs are cool right now.
It has a moment.
This is not something that we grew up with
even 20 years ago and so,
what's happening is,
like anything that's cool,
rappers, athletes, or anything else,
there's a lot of young
people that aspire to be
what is cool.
Entrepreneurship is cool.
Which leads to a lot of people that
want to become that.
I think there's a lot of cynicism
a lot of times on the inner city of
you think the only way out is
being a rapper or an athlete.
I think that's happening
with white America
and the rest of the world right now
around entrepreneurship.
Everybody thinks that's their way out.
Unlike a lot of other things,
when you claim that
you're an entrepreneur,
everybody starts watching.
From your parents,
to your friends, to the world.
And everybody will watch you fail,
and you have to be very emotionally strong
to deal with that loss.
That is very different than
getting bad grades in school,
that is very different
you get fired from a
job, you blame the boss.
Your business fails, it's your fault
and there's no escaping it.
I'm very concerned about
the post-game of this era
of people getting into
depression and even worse.
Which is why I'm talking
about self-awareness
and truths that make people uncomfortable.
It's not fun for me to say that
98 percent of people out there
aren't gonna succeed.
It doesn't make me feel
cool and them not cool.
It's just something we need to talk about
so we're prepared for the ramifications
of the glorifying of the
entrepreneurial journey.
(hip hop music)
- [Crowd Member] Gary!
- [Gary] What up?
Good to see you.
Things are good, bro.
- What do you think of
my little pod here, dude?
- It's fuckin' awesome!
- Pretty badass, isn't it?
- Oh you have wrestling figures?
- We got everything, man!
- [Gary] Fuckin' Macho Man!
That's what's up!
- [Male] That's what's up, homies!
- [Gary] Macho Man, baby!
- I went to school in one
of these short buses, man.
I was in Special Ed.
- I love it.
- Learning disabilities
and now I go around and help people.
- That's really fuckin' rad.
You gotta understand.
I was really selling
stuff at a very young age.
I'm talkin' first grade.
- Shit.
- Like even looking at
this brings back memories,
buy the bag, get a discount.
(laughs)
Sell them for a quarter.
You know, like,
so,
I, long before entrepreneurship was cool.
Long before I had anybody to look up to
it was in me.
In the same way that people like
sang or wrote poems,
it was deeply in me.
So, very early on, I was like
fuck school.
I'm not gonna win at this game.
I was super into the social parts.
- Yep.
- I had a lot of friends,
I loved being popular,
I loved being popular with
the coolest kid in school,
and the biggest nerd.
- Nerd?
- Nah.
- She's pretty badass.
(laughs)
- She's so fuckin' confident.
She's the most confident person
on my whole team.
(laughs)
But you know what I mean?
I enjoy, I took a lot of pride in
being friendly with everybody.
I remember that being a big theme for me.
- Empathy, right?
- Yeah.
That's exactly right.
- Big on empathy?
- It's my superpower.
I'm grateful for having
so many natural talents.
So for me it's less about insecurity
and I gotta prove it or stick it.
Though I love that and I love competition.
I like, I want to beat everybody.
But not,
more what's driving me is
fuck!
I was gifted with the best ingredients.
I better get my chef game up,
to make this dish.
Because I was given
- I was a chef for 15 years
- I love it, it's a great analogy.
I've gotta get my chef game up.
I've been given the best foie gras
the best beef from Japan
and Argentina.
The best vegetables
and fuck, I better make the greatest meal.
Because if somebody makes a better meal
than me, with less
because the ingredients were given.
(laughs)
- Nah, I hear you.
- So, for me, it's about
how do I keep challenging myself
to become the best chef in the world?
Because my DNA's off the fuckin' charts.
My origin is fucking all-time.
(hip hop music)
- [Male] Love you.
- [Gary] Thank you
brother, good luck to you.
No worries, man.
(applauding)
- You can only line up
if you have a gold bracelet.
If you do not have a gold bracelet,
I'm sorry, you cannot be here right now.
- If you don't have a gold bracelet,
what the fuck?
(audience laughs)
I am gonna hope to put pressure
on everybody in this room to get
really self aware really fast.
I think the reason I have a happy life
and things have gone well,
and more importantly, forget about me
being a focus group of one,
everybody that I know
that has happiness traces back to
some incredible, incredible commitment
to self awareness.
An incredible thing happens in your life
when you stop bullshitting yourself.
It's incredible to me
that you can start a brand
from zero, have a smart
Instagram and Facebook strategy,
sell it on Shopify Plus,
and Amazon, and build a real
business in a year or two.
That is remarkable, that is incredible,
and that is what makes this era special.
Let me tell you this again,
and I referenced it earlier.
My friends, humans will
look back at this era,
they will look back at this era,
you are living in one of
those interesting times
that will be reviewed
over and over and over,
because you lived during the era of
the internet being established,
Blockchain being established.
This is big fuckin' shit.
This is printing press, this is big.
This is big, big, big, big, big.
And so now what you have to do is
be on the offense, practically.
I am so frustrated by watching all the
teenagers and 20 year
olds take full advantage
of this opportunity because
they don't know any better.
And for the 40 and 50 and 60 year olds
closing their mind without realizing
that they're gonna live
for the next 40 years
and this fuckin' land grab is for you too
and good news, old fuckers,
you have experience
(applauding)
I'm fuckin' 42!
I'm not fuckin' young.
I'm not a baby.
I just understand how
good the opportunity is,
and I struggle with my 46 and 59 and 60,
70 year old friends
who think, because that's how we grew up,
that they're getting
to the end of the years
without recognizing how
much healthier we are
as a race in our 70's, 80's and 90's,
you compound how fast
medicine is advancing.
There's, the pharma
I mean if you're 40 to 60 in this room,
your numbers are gonna look like 100,
110, like, what do people
think is happening here?
And if you're 63 in this room,
and you're living another 50 years,
you're only at half-time.
But when we grew up, you
were towards the end.
And I am imploring everybody in this room
from the youngest of fuckers in this room
to the oldest of fuckers in this room
(audience laughs)
I'm imploring you to understand
how incredible this is
which is the following.
Ronald fuckin' Reagan ran the free world
with a computer not as powerful as this,
only five minutes ago.
Shit's happening.
And you need to take
advantage of your thing.
And the fact that most of you are
not taking advantage of this opportunity,
because of the insecurities that your
fucked-up parents, or your
neighborhood gave to you
breaks my fuckin' heart.
And I am completely obsessed
with putting out content
at scale to get people to understand
that not posting on things on social media
because johnnypants47
said you're ugly or stupid
(audience laughs)
watching my 60 year old
friends not do things
because they feel weird of the judgment
of their grandkids making fun of them that
they don't understand how to use Snapchat,
remind your 13 year old granddaughter
that she doesn't know jackshit about life!
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member] Gary,
can you sign my book?
I just drove from New Jersey from Toronto.
- [Gary] And so I really
really need people
to understand what's
actually happening here
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- [Audience Member] I drove
from New Jersey to Toronto
this weekend, nine hours.
- [Gary] If you are not
communicating to the world,
on these platforms, you're invisible.
Fix it.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
Alright, one more.
One more, one more, one more.
- [Audience Member]
You're actually the reason
I dropped out of school four years ago.
(audience laughs)
- Aaron, real quick,
Aaron, real quick are your parents here?
(audience laughs)
- [Aaron] They weren't happy at the time
but they're pretty happy
now so it's all good.
- Go fuckin' figure!
- [Aaron] Anyways, last four years,
my brothers and I we
built a franchise now,
seven locations actually in the city.
We sell
but what's been happening recently is
after spending my time, my nights
on some other things.
- 'kay.
- [Aaron] I want to
know how you feel about
diversifying streams of income
other people are like, you should be
putting 110 percent into that one thing
which I am, but
- I think that you're entrepreneurial,
and you're curious,
and even if what you're doing at night
completely fails,
you needed to scratch that itch
and it's 100 percent ROI positive.
- [Aaron] Thing is, it's
growing crazy right now.
- Go figure.
(audience laughs)
- [Aaron] Only so many hours in the day.
I can sleep four every
night but at some point
- Listen I think it comes down to
are you willing to fuck your brothers?
(audience laughs)
See ya!
(applauding)
(hip hop music)
What's up, brother?
- [Male] Can you sign this for me?
- [Gary] I sure can.
- Thanks man, I appreciate it.
- What's your name?
- Dave.
(rock n' roll-influenced hip hop music)
- If you were 16, what would
you go back and tell yourself?
- You know to be very
frank, I would tell myself
that I was right.
At 16 I had a very strong vision.
Even though it wasn't
obvious that I was an
I was a businessman.
- Yeah.
- And that
even though college and
my guidance counselor
were telling me that I was a loser
and this and that, I was focused.
- Yeah.
- And I was willing to give up a lot
to get to where I wanted.
And I'm glad I did.
- Yeah.
Alright, that's awesome.
- Simple as that.
Nice meeting you.
- How do you suggest I document
and not create when
my life feels like it's
kinda boring though.
- Everybody's life is boring.
- Yeah, so what do you suggest?
- Just fuckin' do it.
- Alright, alright, thank you.
- This is not a joke,
I want to know where you bought that.
I want to know where you
bought that Champion.
That's interesting
- Downtown.
(laughs)
- Know what I mean?
- Yeah yeah.
- Everything's interesting.
- Yeah, alright.
- We're all interesting to each other,
we're not interesting to ourselves.
- I got it, yeah.
Thanks.
- I'll be honest, I've
only been following you
for about four months
- Thank you.
- But, it's been
- It's been a great four months!
- It's been, like, I read all your books,
I'm buying your shoes
and you got your book
that's been fantastic.
- Thank you.
- I hear you're a pickle guy.
- I am.
- These are actually
from here in Hamilton.
Family owned and operated.
- Pickles!
I love pickles.
- And you're kosher as well so
- I love it.
Thank you very much.
And root beer?
- And pop shop
- I love it.
- One for Iris and you and Tyler.
- Tyler!
Tyler take some root beer.
Thank you brother.
You're never gonna believe this.
This is real.
Hey vlog, this is real shit.
Literally, literally
yesterday in the office
I wish I said something.
I walked by a Vaynerchuk 73
that I have in my office,
and I said to myself,
with the whole five thing,
it's just gonna be a moment
any moment, somebody's gonna
make me a Vaynerchuk five.
Fuckin' fresh, man.
I fuckin' love it.
- A couple questions, so basically,
so like two weeks ago,
my personal life has been
really good and my work
life is really good.
I'm a filmmaker so I was doing projects
but then a bunch of stuff
started happening to me
in my personal life,
and I've been really
unmotivated to do any projects.
- It's only been two weeks!
- Yeah.
- Is it really bad?
- Yeah it's kinda bad.
- Somebody died?
- Well, my grandma's in the hospital and
my girlfriend broke up with me and
- Dude, you just need a couple weeks.
Let me tell you something,
you're so young, you can't judge your life
based on two weeks.
You could be in a slump for three months
but then in four months, you're back.
Don't judge yourself
for not being productive
while you're being emotional.
Put it into perspective.
It's fuckin' two weeks,
three months out of your entire life.
Doesn't mean shit!
You're gonna get a better girlfriend.
You're gonna like it better.
- Very first book from you.
- A classic!
- Yes!
- Iris,
you were like 13 when this shit came out!
(laughs)
- Question, for someone who
grew up with a hard childhood,
how do they overcome that?
- [Gary] By yelling out loud
the poison that was.
- Okay, other question
- The way you own it
is by putting it out there.
- Alright.
- It's owning you because of its secrets.
Thanks man.
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- Once you put it out, it's over.
Look, this entire evening
is why I'm emotional.
You guys, so many of you
are keeping a secret inside
that's just insecurities
that your mom gave you
or your dad gave you or
your older sibling gave you.
A lot of you are sitting with them.
Half of you are sitting with them.
I met you tonight.
The fact that I know that if
you made a video right now
and just told your truth,
if you did, if you did, if you did
if you just took fuckin'
Instagram right now,
flipped it, and said it,
it would change your fuckin' life.
Your poison is your secret.
You can't imagine what
your secret's doing to you.
You want a little Airport Gary, Iris?
- [Iris] Yeah.
- I mean it's only half
Airport Gary, Iris.
But, I already got the beanie but I can
switch to a different beanie.
- [Iris] I have your other one.
- I, it's okay.
Iris, I'm gonna give it to you.
Here we go.
One.
Number one.
Guys, fuckin' intensity.
Toronto, I fuckin' love
your city so fuckin' much.
I just, love this fuckin' city.
And I just want everybody to know,
when you're putting out good shit,
good shit comes back.
Shit's so basic.
Please allow me to be the permission
for you to try to live your
life the way you want to.
Please allow me that amazing gift.
If you don't do it for me,
do it for Airport Gary.
See ya.
(reflective piano music)